i will walk the great spiral
and i will let the mother the maiden and
the crone decide what is true
who is right
and who is wrong
hey guys pete here i wasn't planning on
making another foundation video before
the recap for episode 7 and then i saw
all these new previews they put out in
the last few days this will be a quick
one but i just wanted to put something
together after seeing some of these
shots to see what other people think
might be going on in them there will be
potential spoilers for the rest of the
first season of foundation so if you're
not into that this is your chance to
leave before i get into the more
interesting stuff apple tv plus put out
two exclusive clips for the upcoming
episode 7 which isn't something i've
seen them do since the premiere i'll put
links to both of these in the
description so you can watch them in
full if you want to the first one was on
tvline.com and features brother day at
the salt palace trying to prove he has a
soul to the followers of the luminous
faith he says that he'll walk the great
spiral to let the goddesses decide what
is true who is right and who is wrong
it's his plan to go against halima so if
he completes this i guess he'll have
some credibility with the faithful the
second clip was on the rotten tomatoes
youtube channel and featured brother
dawn and azora and a backup brother dawn
in a tank as it were he's explaining to
her that he'll be destroyed and replaced
if his brothers find out he's different
which we can see is already starting to
happen which means he's in a pretty
rough spot this is the first we've seen
that they have backups and it looks like
his days may be numbered the final thing
that came out was on the apple tv
youtube channel it's called the saga
featurette and it's a mixture of stuff
we've already seen and some crazy
looking shots from the rest of the
season i'm just gonna go through this
and point out all the new stuff that we
haven't seen yet the first thing that
jumps out here is this completely
different looking ship swooping down on
terminus you can see the little flags on
the ground where people marked how close
they were able to get to the vault and
we see even more of this later so we'll
come back to it then we see salvor on a
ship i'm assuming this is the bridge of
the invictus considering the summary of
episode 7 which says the enactrions and
their hostages board the fabled warship
there's another shot of day in front of
the salt palace that looks like it's
connected to the spiral clip there's a
shot of hugo in the same place we saw
salvor on the invictus behind him we see
the anacryon soldier rowan who was with
pharah's group and then another
character in front of him who's dressed
differently someone we haven't seen
before and someone who doesn't look
particularly
that's followed by salvor wearing the
suit on a ship that could be hugo's the
one they left terminus on at the end of
the last episode or it could also be the
invictus then there's this shot of
gail's cryopod entering synaxis's
atmosphere which doesn't really add up
that's followed by another shot where we
see her inside the pod the reason it
doesn't add up is that we see another
shot of gail on the ship where we last
saw her and it looks like harry's
standing behind her and then there's
another quick shot of harry glitching
that looks like it picks up right where
we left them there's an unrelated shot
of day breaking some glass which is more
or less without context it looks like
this might be inside the palace which
you have to guess is taking place after
he returns from his trip he has his
house clothes on and that made me think
of this scene i saw yesterday when i was
editing my book to show video but i went
back and watched it and don't see the
exact same angle it's possible though
this might be brother day smashing the
glass to where they keep the original
cleon we see salvor outside in the suit
again and this is probably on the
invictus it looks like there's a gun
mounted behind her and she's screaming
about something that she's watching and
then we see that there's a battle going
on she sort of rolls to the ground to
avoid getting shot this probably follows
this other shot where we see her in the
suit approaching the invictus which is
similar to what we saw in the trailer
before the season came out and there's
one last shot of salvor on the ship
she's looking at someone through a
window and it looks like she might be
saying goodbye to hugo there's a shot at
gail swimming in something that's
submerged which is probably connected to
this other shot of her and her pod in
the water in synax the reason i'm
thinking at synax is because while she's
from there but then also the rings which
were in all the wide shots we saw from
earlier in the season when we were there
she's wearing the same clothes that she
was wearing in the shot of her swimming
earlier then there's this battle scene
on terminus rowan is there and he looks
like he's a prisoner and there's another
group of soldiers which are probably
connected to that ship from earlier
these don't look like the imperial
soldiers we've seen and then who does
that leave the only other place i could
think of would be thespis since it's
established that they hate anacrion they
could actually help terminus out if it
came down to it but based on cleon's
attacks on their planet after the star
bridge i'm not sure they're even capable
of being there and blowing stuff up plus
it looks like there's an ongoing battle
they have rowan and they look to be in
control on the ground but someone looks
like they're attacking them all of
that's interesting but it's not the
thing that stands out the most because
in the background you can see that the
vault is open so that's happening and
there appears to be some real fighting
going on in front of it it just looks
open you can't really see anything else
maybe there's some light coming out it's
kind of hard to say against that
background there's a shot of a pretty
ragged looking brother day kinda
sunburnt and covered with dust or sand
where he's grabbing a human skull this
is probably happening on his journey on
the spiral and the skull i guess is
showing you that people die when they
try to do this
and then this trailer closes out with
another shot of gail on the ship looking
at what i'm presuming is the dark star
on her trip to helicon again this looks
like harry is standing behind her he's
probably a hologram but he looks like
he's right there with her in the voice
over we hear say that we're not turning
around but it's all kind of hard to
figure out because these shots are
somehow connected to the ones where
she's on synax so some interesting stuff
and it raises quite a few questions it
looks like salvor and pharah get to the
invictus but then they come back to
terminus and then maybe the anacrions
are prisoners in that situation i don't
know what that says about the invictus
so we'll have to wait and see with that
something's going on with the vault so i
wonder if that's not the 9th or 10th
episode that we're seeing there and then
gail's all over the place it looks like
she's on her way to helicon with harry
and then what she dips out there is this
one shot where we see her getting into
the cryo pod is it all part of the plan
for her to go back to synax and if so
why doesn't look like there's anybody
there that would probably take a long
time to get there in that little cryopod
and when she arrives it does look like
she's pretty much stuck there alone and
i think that's probably a good place to
leave things i just wanted to take a
look at it all and see what you guys are
thinking so let me know in the comments
what do you think's happening in some of
these shots how do you think the
season's gonna come to an end please
like this video if you enjoyed it please
subscribe to my channel if you haven't
already and thanks for watching i'll
talk to you soon